actually it's it's remarkable just how
much energy is involved in in doing
these calculations associated with
Bitcoin mining the way that it's
approached right across the internet is
for a number of years has been well
let's look at well how many hash
attempts are being taken how many you
know what's the what's the the greater
of actually attempting to crack this
code we're gonna put it in that context
versus what's the sort of energy cost in
terms the efficiency of the hardware
that's being used to solve this that's
one aspect of the puzzle a better way of
doing it which is describing this rather
good paper which I'm sure Shawn will
link to below is to look at the
economics but for me from a physicist
perspective it's really quite neat in
many ways from many perspectives it's
what's called a Fermi problem so a Fermi
problem the physicist Fermi was really
adept at working out reasonable
estimates for quantities a really good
example is just here's a row of question
how many passed and this was the first
sort of or the archetypal Fermi problem
how many piano tuners are there in
Chicago or would you do that how many
piano tuners are there in Nottingham so
you got to think about well first one
you get hit by dampe I don't know how am
I going to answer that let's look at
estimates so let's think about right
what's the population how many people do
you have per house you know let's say
probably listen or Notting let's do it
for Notting 300,000 I need you have per
house see two or three somewhere like
that maybe two and a half kids but let's
go with two just as an example so many
what fraction of households would have a
piano don't know five percent then we'd
have to think about how often does a
piano need to be tuned
I don't know once a year maybe let's say
once a year you take up all these and
you stack them up and you get piled upon
estimate but what's remarkable is that
you can get our pretty good estimate in
many cases obviously each one of those
estimates has got its own error value on
its own certainty but sometimes what we
want to do is get to you know calculate
to the nth decimal place all the times
we just want those estimates and when
you're coming back to the Bitcoin issue
and the energy consumption issue so when
you look across the web you'll find many
many different estimates and it's
effectively a Fermi problem cuz nobody
really knows nobody really knows know
unless you can take each piece of
equipment or each
piece of hardware and say you know
somebody could be running the absolute
state-of-the-art kit and then somebody
could have a farmer player stations
we're not gonna get a very you know an
estimate that's accurate to the nth
decimal place but we can at least think
about well could we put a lower limit on
this well let's think about you know
absolute state of the art and let's
think about the energy efficiency of the
absolute state of the art this paper was
quite useful because we turn to Table
one we find right at the top and I'm
sure many in the audience will be much
more familiar with this than I am this
this equipment ant minor s9 house radar
14 tera hashes per second so terror 10
to the 12 we find that the power
efficiency so the joules per gig a hash
so the amount of energy that's chewed up
a Giga hash which means a total of 10 to
the 9 hash calculations per second is
off the order of point zero nine eight
joules per gig aha Sh
it's a very recent paper but what you
can see is they the power efficiency so
we need to think about well how many
actual operations how many attempts
house attempts are happening per second
and it is an absolute astronomical
number literally astronomical
it's 2.6 by 10 to the 18 per second
that's what's have you know that's the
number of hash attempts that are
happening across the entire sort of
Bitcoin ecosystem if you want to put it
which is a remarkable number it is truly
astronomical because the number of
galaxies in the observable universe is
only a four to ten to the nine so this
is 10 to the 9 by 10 to the 9 that
number that's just a mind-boggling ly
astronomical number so it's 10 to the 18
so that's 10 to the 9 Giga hush let's
put it that way so that means what we
have to do is to is we need to take this
number this point 0 9 8 I multiply it by
the 2.6 by 10 to the 9 we work that out
it turns out that we are talking about
2.6 gigawatts of power so I've just
translated there from power to energy
remember power is the rate of doing work
which is a rate of energy expenditure
effectively which is different from
energy will come back and think of
energy in a second so it's the
difference between
example kilowatts power and kilowatt
hours energy but you work it out and it
turns out to be 2 point off the order
2.6 gigawatts adding on lots of other
decimal places pointless because of the
estimates that we've used in there in
fact you could make an argument that
even having one decimal place under this
circumstance is probably pushing it
because we have sown this this is just
really we're thinking about a lower
limit we do not know actually obviously
all machines involved in Bitcoin mining
are not of this specification we also
haven't bundled in for example the costs
associated with cooling we haven't
bowled in and this is this is purely the
efficiency we haven't bundled in cost to
sorted we actually move with making the
devices as well so there are capital
cost an or usage cost etc so it really
is it's a physics problem but it's also
a coupled physics and economic problem
one of the first papers I've got a lot
of attention that looked into this was
from some researchers in Ireland back in
2014 two months ago watts is not that
far removed from the 3.1 gigawatts of
that Ireland uses which is given my
accent is fairly close to home close to
my heart and it's now there's a website
called dizzy Cana masti can look up the
the current energy consumption and all
the values associated with with Bitcoin
mining and we're now we've gone beyond
Ireland and we're now up I think it
exceeds czech republic's consumption so
and and it's it's going up it's steadily
going up so if you go to that digi
Kannamma site which I thoroughly
recommend there are many items
associated but one of those items is the
the the cost per transaction basically
in terms of the energy cost in terms of
kilowatts per hour and it turns out that
it's off the order of per transaction of
a thousand kilowatts per hour stiff
achill to put that in sort of context
sometimes but that's an awful lot of
energy when you total it up in terms of
cost per kilowatt hour in the UK that's
something like it fluctuates obviously
but it's something like 14 pence per
kilowatt hour in the u.s. something like
12 like this paper produces much smaller
estimates in terms of its averages
talking about
five cents per kilowatt-hour anyway
we're talking about orders of magnitude
it's Fermi problem again and you add
that up and you compare 14 pence per
kilowatt hour times a thousand kilowatt
hours there's a question and a cooling
if you've got massive farms you've
obviously got out in the financial cost
of keeping them cool you've got a guess
that you know the borrow goes up and
open up and open up in terms of the
computational power you need to process
this and it's built into the system to
have this sort of arms race in terms of
building up that the complexity so
you've got to build that in you've got
to keep your kit up to date but you add
that all in still at the moment the pure
economics of this or is that we haven't
hit the ceiling not 2.6 Gillick
gigawatts is definitely not the ceiling
there's an awful lot more in terms of
where the the energy is going to upscale
I've just got a stress they'll remember
these are all estimates that's they
would coming back to that Fermi problem
idea that's what we're doing you might
say we're plucking values out of the
thin air
we're not that you know they're
obviously informed values but it makes
me smile when I see you know people
quoting these values two three and four
decimal places when the error bar is
like that and our quotient with a
precision like that the interesting
thing courses this is considering the
whole system on aggregate for the
individual prospector as it were for the
individual miner is there's a hell of a
lot of risk or there can be a hell of a
lot of risk involved and you've got a
you know depends on how brave you are I
guess financially whether you want to
take that risk so this is how Bitcoin
mining works right in brief so we have a
block and at the top of the block is the
hash of the previous block and a number
right which we're going to call our
nonce this is a number we're making up